I'm addicted to internet personality
tests for instance my inner Disney
Princess Belle
I'm an ENFP on the myers-briggs a7 wing
six on the Enneagram and a Gryffindor
duh
those can be fun but most of them don't
have much practical use that's such an
NEA gram one thing to say
however psychologists and financial
practitioners around the globe have
started to identify a myriad of distinct
money personalities now this isn't an
exact science but rather a lens that you
can look through to better understand
your own money habits the names vary
slightly but there are six main types
that seem to be emerging uncovering your
personal money sign might just be the
Loadstar that can guide you to a more
healthy relationship with your money do
you love playing the stock market do you
spend your free time research and
cryptocurrency and emerging tech are you
a motley full premium subscriber if you
feel called out then you might be a risk
taker the great thing about this type is
their high financial literacy and
openness to talking about money however
there are some hang-ups greg davies who
headed a financial behavior department
at Barclays observes that hopping from
one opportunity to the next fires up the
pleasure centers in the brain the longer
you stay in an addictive environment the
more prone you are to bad decisions
which causes anxiety which leads to
overtraining and therefore more anxiety
so if this is you try your best to slim
down your financial media intake and
consider having a cooler financial head
around you to bounce ideas off of before
you start learning how to day trade or
invest in your mother's best friends
surefire business idea
next up the hoarder - hoarders money
represents security against the unknowns
of the world building up savings comes
easy to them but there's another side to
that coin punnet
that golden number of ultimate security
seems always just out of reach and the
minute you bring a non hoarder partner
into the mix things can get ugly
activities like vacationing and going to
a nice restaurant may seem threatening
to their stability you can alleviate the
intensity of those fears by having a
cash based budget that way you can
always see where your true savings lies
and you can feel more at ease treating
yourself and taking a calculated risk
now and then hello I'm Julia and I'm a
social spender I love to shop simply for
its own sake but usually not ever
enlarged one-time amounts just small
things all over the place I also love to
buy things for friends family and give
my money away to causes I'm passionate
about to me buying and spending is the
ultimate freedom of expression which can
obviously backfire pretty spectacularly
and if I'm honest I tend to carry around
some shame that my type is inherently
wrong and bound for financial ruin
thankfully for me
I also found peace in you guessed it a
budget even though I was terrified that
budgeting would curb my fun it ended up
cutting the shame strings that were
attached to that spending now with a
flexible plan I can scratch my shopping
itch without sabotaging my future self
next we have those layers of
spreadsheets bean counters
extraordinaire the engineers a type I
know well to us money is a game a game
meant to be won through savvy and
constant vigilance which can sometimes
border on obsession we tend to be
interested in investing but are more
anxious than our risk-taker cousins
likely to scuttle the ship at the first
sign of trouble
Claudia Hammond a psychology lecturer
notes people who find it hard to deal
with the unpredictability of life can
get super organized about money if
you're like me you might consider hiring
a financial professional that can help
you see the forest for the trees and
make sure you're not over complicating
things and if you're partnered with a
different money type a relationship
counselor might not be the worst idea we
all have that friend that has to loudly
clean the check whenever they go out
they also
we have the latest smartphone a luxury
car and designer clothes
that's the Mogul money for them is a
tool meant for a very specific purpose
to achieve higher social status
forget keeping up with the Joneses they
are the Joneses interestingly enough the
social groups that have the highest
prevalence of this behavior tend to have
a history of systemic poverty the
hottest luxury markets in the world are
in countries with below average
household income these visible displays
of wealth are meant to psychologically
combat the perception of poverty social
media only exacerbates this situation
pressuring people to compete not just
with their neighbors but with the whole
world
so moguls seeking to be a healthier
version of themselves might consider
limiting their social media interactions
don't let your flex gram of today leave
you scrounging for change in your later
years if I asked you how much you spend
in a month
did you tell me what about how much you
make or what's in your accounts right
now if you're breaking out in hives just
thinking about it then you may be our
last type the ostrich honestly congrats
for being here and watching a financial
video because for you talking about
money brings up all sorts of bad
feelings like here anxiety and disgust
and this could be for many reasons you
might have a lot of shame about your
current situation or have experienced
financial trauma in your past you may be
able to avoid confronting your money
fears for a time but we all know that
creates bigger problems down the road
money avoidance has even been associated
with increased risk of overspending and
compulsive buying you'll have to get
your head out of the sand but you
probably won't be able to do it alone
find someone who can hold your hand and
help you work through things like your
spending habits or your debt picture I
promise 90 percent of the time the
situation isn't nearly as bad as
ostriches imagined it to be
darkness often acts like a steroid to
your fear so take a deep breath and text
your most supportive friend you got this
while you may resonate more strongly
with one or two of these types it's
important to remember we're all
ultimately a mix we contain multitude
your personal money style is formed by
your family history worldview and
experiences and it's neither good nor
bad the goal of identifying your sign is
not to change it but hopefully empower
you to become a healthier version of
your type and in our personal and
professional experience taking the time
to get to know yourself better is one of
the best investments you can make and
that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description to become a two cents
patron ok we got to ask what's your
money sign let us know in the comments
[Music]